[Music]
programming to take your life to
Hiroshima Japan that is the U.S
President Joe Biden holding a news
conference after attending the G7 Summit
let's listen in with all four
Congressional leaders
and we agreed the only way to move
forward was in a bipartisan agreement
I've done my part
we put forward a proposal to cut
spending by more than a trillion dollars
and on top of the nearly three trillion
dollars in deficit reduction that I
previously proposed through the
combination of spending cuts and new
revenues
now it's time for The Other Side to move
they're from their extreme positions
because much of what they've already
proposed is simply uh quite frankly
unacceptable
and so let me be clear I'm not going to
agree to a deal that protects for
example 30 billion dollar tax break for
the oil industry which made 200 billion
dollars last year they don't need an
incentive another 30 billion dollars
while putting health care of 21 million
Americans at risk by going after
Medicaid
I'm not going to agree to a deal that
protects 200 billion dollars in excess
payments for pharmaceutical Industries
and refusing to count that
while cutting over a hundred thousand
School teachers and uh and assistance
jobs thirty thousand Law Enforcement
Officers jobs cut across the the entire
United States of America I'm not going
to agree to a deal that protects wealthy
tax sheets and crypto Traders while
putting food assistance at risk for
nearly a hundred well assuming nearly 1
million Americans and it's time for
Republicans to accept that there is no
bipartisan deal
to be made solely solely on their
partisan terms
they have to move as well
all four Congressional leaders agree
with me that that default is not let me
say it again default is not an option
and I expect each of the I expect each
of these leaders excuse me to live up to
that commitment
America has never defaulted never
defaulted on our debt and it never will
the speaker and I'll be talking later on
the plane as we head back because it's
about five or six success at seven
o'clock in the morning there and our
teams are going to continue working now
we've had a uh we've had a pack few days
here in Hiroshima and I think with very
productive important meetings at the G7
Summit
we also held the quad meeting here in
Hiroshima rather than Australia
an important bilateral discussions the
primary of Japan prime minister Albanese
of Australia and president zielinski of
Ukraine as well as the prime minister of
India this is my third trip to the
indo-pacific as president and I look
forward to rescheduling my stops in
Papua New Guinea and Australia later
I've spoken with the Prime Minister
Papua New Guinea and secretary Lincoln
is traveling there to meet with the
Pacific island Partners at that moment
and I'm also going to be hosting and
I've spoken with the Prime Minister
hosting the leaders of the Pacific
island Forum in Washington this fall
because I've only unable to make it to
Papua New Guinea and the Prime Minister
Albanese we're going to have a state
visit later this year and I also want to
thank president kashida for his
outstanding I'm not it's not hyperbole
he's outstanding leadership of the G7
this year as well as Mrs kashid and the
entire Japanese government for the
hospitality they've shown to Jill myself
on our whole team being in this city and
visiting the memorial on Friday
was a powerful reminder of the
devastating reality of nuclear war
and our shared responsibility to never
cease our efforts to build for peace
and together with the leaders of the G7
we have read it we have reiterated our
commitment to continue to work toward a
world free from the threat of nuclear
weapons
over the past few days have showcased
the unity the unity of purpose among the
G7 it's a very different organization
than it was five seven ten years ago
because we're addressing the challenges
that matter most to the world
we're United in our efforts to
strengthen Global Health security
and yesterday announced that the United
States plans to contribute another 250
million dollars to the pandemic fund at
the World Bank to make sure the world is
better prepared to prevent detect and
respond to Future pandemics
we're uniting our commitment to climate
action and accelerating the transition
to a global clean energy economy by
investing in the industries of the
future
we're United in our push to build a more
resilient and inclusive global economy
that can better withstand the kinds of
shocks that we've experienced over the
last few years including by building a
more secure and more Diversified supply
chain
through the partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment which we
launched last year at the G7 Summit in
Germany and we've addressed the
infrastructure needs that are holding
back too many low and modern income
countries particularly in the global
South
the United States has already mobilized
more than 30 billion dollars in pgii
projects around the globe a significant
step toward our our Collective Pledge of
the G7 to mobilize 600 billion dollars
in investment by 2027.
and we've resolved to reform the
multilateral development Banks to begin
the more flexibility and better able to
fight poverty by helping respond to
Global challenges
now we're also uniting our approach the
People's Republic of China
and the joint statement released
yesterday outlines the shared principles
we've all agreed at the G7 and Beyond
dealing with China
we're not looking to decouple from China
we're looking to de-risk and diversify
our relationship with China that means
taking steps to diversify our supply
chains and we're not so we're not
dependent on any one country for
necessary product
it means resisting economic coercion
together encountering harmful practices
that hurt our workers means protecting a
narrow set of Advanced Technologies
critical for our national security
and those elements are all agreed on by
the G7
finally joined here in Hiroshima by
President zielinski and the G7
reaffirmed our shared and unwavering let
me say it again our shared and
unwavering commitment to stand with the
brave people of Ukraine as they defend
themselves against Russia's brutal war
of aggression and the war crimes being
committed together with our partner
countries we reiterated a need for a
just peace that respects Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
both core principles of the UN Charter
Russia started this war and Russia had
ended today by withdrawing his troops
from Ukraine internationally recognized
borders and ceasing its assault
until then excuse me the ability
Ukraine's ability to defend itself is
essential to being able to end this war
permanently and through diplomacy you
know and this morning I once more shared
and assured president zielinski together
with all G7 members and our allies and
partners around the world that we will
not waver
Putin will not break our resolve as he
thought he could two years ago almost
three years ago we're going to continue
to provide economic humanitarian and
security assistance to Ukraine so it can
stand strong as long as it needs you and
today the United States announced our
latest tranche of artillery ammunition
anti-tank weapons and bridging equipment
to help Ukraine succeed in the
battlefield
you know in my private meeting with
president zielinski after the G7 meeting
and with his staff I told the United
States together with our allies and
partners is going to begin training
Ukrainian pilots in fourth generation
fighter aircraft including f-16s to
strengthen Ukraine's Air Force as part
of a long-term commitment to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself we provided the
last year all that they needed to deal
with what they were dealing with at the
moment and that's when now we're moving
in the direction of putting him in
position to be able to be defend
themselves in ways beyond what they've
had to deal with so far
past few days have once more underscored
how important America's Global
Leadership is presumptuous thing for
American president to say but I think
you'll find if you ask any of our
colleagues is true the security and
prosperity of the American people are
substantially increased by working in
concert with our closest allies and
partners to build a future
of Greater economic strength and
resilience and a world that is more
peaceful and stable
and on many of these issues that matter
to the American people accelerating our
clean energy transition preventing
another pandemic dealing with China
standing up for Ukraine the meetings
I've had with my fellow G7 leaders have
left us more united
more resolved the more determined to set
up for the greater progress in the
months ahead
and this has been an extremely
significant and important Summit with
that I'm going to take some questions
and
Trevor of Reuters
you spoke a moment ago about What You
Won't Do in terms of your negotiations
with Republicans but I'm interested in
what you've signaled you already might
do
in particular by conceding in these
negotiations to some form of a cap or
freezing spending are you concerned that
Mr McCarthy has already forced you into
accepting a policy position that could
tip this economy into a recession
no uh I don't believe that's the case at
all as a matter of fact uh I think that
uh is we can reach an agreement as I've
told you and you may be aware you've
seen it we have provided for a
proposal that would cut a trillion
dollars off the Baseline spent from the
year before by just agreeing to deal
with what was initially offered and uh
secondly we're in a situation where the
let me put it this way if you all were
doing your budget at home
and you said okay we have to make some
cuts
would you only look at the spending
would you also look at your income
what was coming in the door to determine
what you could afford
and so part of what I've been arguing
from the beginning
is a need to consider the tax structure
as well as as well as cutting spending
I'm willing to cut spending and I
propose Cuts in spending of over a
trillion dollars
but I believe we have to also look at
the tax revenues the idea that the my
Republican colleagues want to continue
the two trillion dollar tax cut that had
profound negative impacts on the economy
from the Trump Administration
the fact that they are we've provided
for the number we've got a lot of uh
input from serious economists and former
Administration officials in both parties
that we need more people who are
qualified to be able to look at the tax
returns of the Thousand billionaires in
America very complicated stuff it's
estimated that if we had the appropriate
number of tax
tax Personnel that we would save
somewhere between we would be generated
it's not somewhere between uh 200
billion and 400 billion dollars in tax
revenue
and there's a lot of other for example
the idea that we're in terms of uh taxes
that they refuse to for example we
I was able to balance the budget and
pass everything from the global warming
Bill anyway I was able to
cut by 1.7 billion dollars in the first
two years the deficit that we were were
accumulating and because I was able to
say to it that the 55 corporations in
America that made forty four hundred
billion dollars or 40 billion dollar 400
billion dollars
that they they hit paid zero in tax zero
and so we said you got to pay a minimum
15 taxes what a horrible thing you're
paying more than fifty percent of taxes
every one of you out there and so guess
what we not only balance the budget we
we were able to reduce the deficit by
1.7 billion dollars and so there's a lot
of things that they refuse to look at in
terms of tax generation
as well as what kind of people were
going to increase taxes for like I said
we're now down to we went from roughly
740 billionaires to a about a thousand
billionaires in America they're paying
an average tax rate of eight percent
raise your hand if you want to pay eight
percent only I think you'd all be ready
to do that so my point is that there's a
lot of things that they refuse to
entertain and they just said revenue is
off the table
well revenue is not off the table and so
that's what I continue we continue to
have a significant disagreement on on
the revenue side
I know they won't
now I know they won't matter of fact
the fact that we were able to uh uh cut
government spending by 1.7 trillion
dollars that didn't cause a recession
that caused growth
look we have the the lowest unemployment
rate in over 50 years we've created 12
point I think it's 7 million new jobs
including 800 000 manufacturing jobs we
have moved in a direction where we're
rebuilding and reconstructing America
through the through the in the
infrastructure Act
look here's the other thing
I'm sure I'm not sure my guess is I'll
get a question about you know well wait
a minute you know
the American people aren't satisfied
well guess what as I told you all before
most of this what we passed doesn't kick
in oh it only kicks in over time
and so the fact is for example that if
you're in a situation where you were
I'll give you the one example of I've
used everybody understands easiest is
insulin well I decided that we were
going to be in a position where we were
not going to continue to pay the highest
drug prices in the world and that's what
we do by the way same manufacture of a
drug in the United States selling it
here in Japan selling it in Tokyo or
selling it in Berlin or selling it
around the world they pay a lot less
than we pay at home
so we said a simple proposition let's
take a look at how much it costs to make
the product
and I'm not going to ask you to show a
hands like you're doing a town meeting
but if I usually ask how many people
know somebody who has Type 1 or type 2
diabetes and almost at least half the
audience raises their hand
well they were paying somewhere between
four and seven hundred dollars a month
for their insulin that they badly need
to stay healthy and Alive well guess
what it costs ten dollars t-e-n ten
dollars to make
total amount You could argue maybe as
much as thirteen dollars well guess what
now they can't charge more for Medicare
Camp because Medicare is paying taking
American tax dollars and paying for the
elderly's health care needs you can't
charge more than thirty five dollars for
that that drug that saves 160 billion
dollars
cure it 160 billion dollars less will be
paid out by the by the American taxpayer
to help the elderly people on Medicare
with a problem well a lot of this is
just kicking in we're in a situation
where next year
for the drug costs no senior will have
to pay total cost
total cost of all the drugs from
expensive Cancer drugs to whatever drug
they're taking will not have to pay more
than thirty five hundred dollars a year
the following year we've already passed
this as a law now
the following year they wanted to pay
more than two thousand dollars that
saves another 200 billion dollars that
were paid now but the other team won't
count this even though it's a law we
passed it they won't count that as
reducing the debt
so there's a lot of those kinds of
disagreements we have and my guess is
that I'm going to be talking to uh
to uh the speaker of the house on the
way back on the plane because there'll
be warning time over at home and I'm
going to be in that plane about an hour
or so and my guess is he's going to want
to deal directly with me and making sure
we're all on the same page but that's
probably more than you wanted to know
um
how about uh
um I'm a Savo uh and NHK
good evening Mr President uh the Chinese
military is more active at this time in
the Taiwan Strait which expectations
this might increase leading up to
taiwan's presidential election next
January despite uh despite uh some you
know diplomatic communication recently
between the U.S and China
the military hotline is not working
under this circumstances how will you
manage the Diplomatic you know
relationship with China and how will you
strengthen the U.S alliance with Japan
and are okay in order to counter China
thank you well number one you're right
we should have an open hotline
at the Bali conference that's what the
president she and I agreed we were going
to do in Milan and then this silly
balloon that was carrying
two Freight cars worth of spine
equipmentless line over the United
States and it got shot down and
everything changed in terms of talking
to one another I think you're going to
see that begin to thaw very shortly but
in the meantime
what's happened is I think it's fair to
say for those of you who have dealt with
uh
dealt with the Japanese government and
reported from here for a long time
the situation in terms of our relations
with Japan have never ever ever an
American history been stronger never
never and we started this relationship
when I came to see some of you were with
me by my first trip here when I came to
see president the president because
she's predecessor and made the case that
was happening in Europe it's a small the
world's getting smaller what's happened
in Europe in the invasion of Ukraine is
affects everyone including people here
in the Pacific basin and so we've ended
up where you have Japan stepping up in a
way that's a real consequence in terms
of your defense budget number one and a
beginning approachment with South Korea
I've spoken on length with President
loon of South Korea he came to
Washington of Layton he's agreed we're
all of the same agreement that in fact
we are not going to we're maintaining we
all agree we're going to maintain the
one China policy which says everybody
kind of forgets no I mean you all know
but the public kind of forgets that it
says that neither country Japan I mean
China or Taiwan neither territory can
independently declare what they're going
to do
period there has to be a mutually agreed
new outcome and so what we're we're
sticking by that we're not going to tell
China what they can do we made it clear
that we don't expect we don't expect
Taiwan independently declare
independence either but in the meantime
we're going to continue to put Taiwan in
a position that they can defend
themselves and there is clear
understanding among most of our allies
that in fact if China were to act
unilaterally there would be a response
there would be a response but I so I
don't think there's anything inevitable
about the notion that there's going to
be this conflict between the United
States and the west and or Japan and
Korea and the quad and if you take a
look at what's happened
we are more secure with all the talk
about China's building its military
and it is building its military and
that's why I've made it clear that I am
not going to prepare I'm not prepared to
trade certain items with China and when
I was asked by President XI y I said
because you usually build nuclear
weapons and other weapons of mass
destruction and I'm not going to do it
and we've now got commitment from all of
our allies they're not going to either
provide that kind of material that
allows them to do that but that's not a
hostile act that's an act that says
we're going to make sure that we do
everything we can to maintain the status
quo ending and what's going on now is
the look at the meeting we had here
today uh today and yesterday and the
quad did I bet you I would maybe some of
you thought it but I doubt my many many
people in this audience or any other
audience would have said that two years
had to be elected I'd be able to
convince India
Australia Japan and the United States to
form an organization called the quad to
maintain stability in the Indian Ocean
and the South China Sea
well when asked by the Prime Minister by
uh for president XI why we're doing that
I said simple we have an international
organizations of agreed upon what
constitutes open airspace and sea space
and we're not going to allow that to be
unilaterally altered period
we're not changing any rules we're just
making sure that we unite democracies in
the conviction that the Pacific Basin
remains what it was before open and
clear so I guess what I'm saying and I
don't guess what I'm saying what I'm
trying to say is I think we're more
united than we've ever been ever been in
the Pacific in terms of maintaining
stability and and
maintaining a sense of security
so I'm not sure that answers your
question but I hope it does if it
doesn't you want to follow up with any
portion of that question
well
you're watching Al Jazeera that's the
U.S President Joe Biden he's speaking in
Hiroshima and Japan on the sidelines of
the G7 Summit speaking to reporters
there what he said is that the meetings
of the G7 have been productive this of
course coming after he had met with the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
at the sidelines of the zielinski also
being in attendance and Biden said that
the G7 countries share an unwavering
commitment to stand with the people of
Ukraine he also pointed fingers at
Russia saying that Russia started this
war and Russia can end it and that
Putin excuse me will not break quote our
resolve when it comes to Ukraine let's
bring in Rob McBride he was listening in
to that press conference joining us as
well from Hiroshima in Japan so Rob I
mean a large part of that press
conference was spent addressing sort of
U.S domestic issues by the President
Biden but when it came to the G7
meetings and Ukraine Maine which has
dominated the agenda there he was Keen
to show that all members are united when
it comes to their support and commitment
what do you think the takeaway message
was
well he was uh telling the the the Press
there that the G7 has never been more
united as it is uh at the moment you're
right that a lot of it was taken up with
domestic uh politics he's traveling well
obviously with the White House Press
Corps that is their concern you also get
a sense that that is Joe Biden's concern
at the moment you remember he is cutting
short his visit to Asia Pacific he was
due to go down to uh Australia and to
Papua New Guinea instead of that as he
says there he'll be on a plane in an
hour or so and as soon as they start
waking up in Washington he will be on
the phone dealing with this debt crisis
back in the United States when it comes
to the Ukraine though uh he mentioned
how the unwavering support that Vladimir
zielinski has been shown
um uh saying that the uh that it was
that Russia that started it that uh
Russia must end it and also reminding um
that any kind of peace deal must respect
uh International
respect the sovereignty of a country the
integrity T of a country that seems to
be a sideways swipe at China because
their peace planned controversially
calls for a cease fire but without
Russia first giving up any of its
territory and then finally just in uh
hard dollar terms he talked about the
latest tranche of material that's going
to be sent to Ukraine about the
ammunition and also crucially about the
training of s-16 Pilots of the United
States has given permission finally for
Ukraine to get F-16 planes from some
other European countries other NATO
allies not necessarily the us but did
talk about the giving permission and
also being involved in the training and
then also when it comes to Ukraine
talking about the importance of U.S
leadership he says in having this
Coalition and bringing countries
together to to challenge Russia and its
invasion of Ukraine
okay Rob thank you so much that's our
Rob McBride joining us from Hiroshima in
Japan we'll continue this conversation
with via cheslav matuzov who's a former
Russian Diplomat he's joining us from
Moscow uh via Skype for reaction uh
thanks for joining us on Al Jazeera
first of all so what's your reaction to
what the U.S President Joe Biden has
just said at the press conference really
showing that there's a whole lot of
diplomatic backing for Ukraine by all G7
members and also I'm sure you're aware
earlier on he had announced unveiled a
375 million dollar military aid package
to Ukraine how how will Moscow be
looking at this
it is not for the first time we're here
in a United position of not only G7
but all uh Western World United under a
chairmanship of the United States they
are supporting Ukraine Army Ukraine
Administration very strongly it is not
any new news for for Russia I think
the military assistance a military
[Music]
equipment that were sent to Ukraine Army
they are not respond to any peaceful
efforts where Maiden by some European
countries Asian countries and Arabian
even countries too they were trying to
prepare the play role of
some
countries to bring peace in the uh to
the Ukrainian soil right but now we see
that there is no there is no efforts for
the west countries also but the United
States to bring this situation in
Ukraine from military confrontation to
Peaceful negotiations they are insisting
on destroying Russian foreign
this war and Russia can end it by
withdrawing its troops from Ukraine
uh first of all Russia sent their troops
after very strong efforts to bring uh
relations between the United States and
Russia on equal base to agree on magical
mutual
agreement for uh Security in National
Security because it was very
strange to to listen today that Russia
began the war when in December 1991
Russia suggested to the United States
Administration to Mr Biden to uh to
agree with Russia to sign
an agreement for uh Mutual uh well
Assurance of Independence and security
measures not to threaten Russia not
spreading NATO to the Russian boards
okay let me just jump in there and take
us back to what's happened at the G7
because we also saw that the Ukrainian
president of Vladimir zelenski was in
attendance and not only did he get to
meet members of the G7 but in fact he
met non-member countries he had the
opportunity to be with uh the Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi for one
who's kind of been on the sidelines and
hasn't really taken aside when it comes
to Ukraine or Russia is that going to
bother the Kremlin
well you know Mr Modi who is presented
on G7 in Hiroshima of course but we
remember that Russia has very
strong relations in economical ties with
India this time in spite of the fact
that the United States made all efforts
to prohibit a trade relations between
India and Russia India doesn't obey
American orders that's why India Support
also the tendency the ideas
in
the framework of brics country brics
country India is one of the main
participants by many members of this
organization right
so I can say that there is no United
opinion of all countries to uh what is
going on on European continent okay you
have to leave it there we thank you so
much my apologies but we'll have to
cross back to Hiroshima and listen in to
the Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski who's holding a news
conference right now after attending the
G7 Summit let's listen in
thank you so much
for the important words of support thank
you so much
foreign
Ukraine is in the midst of a war of
Destruction
Invaders have come to our land and they
want not only to conquer us ukrainians
but Russia is lying to the world that
there are new ukrainians
the Russian genocide against tasks could
have succeeded the shadow would be of
Ukraine and from the whole nation just a
shadow but ukrainians are infinitely
Brave infinitely Freedom loving and we
will leave we will live freely although
the enemy is using non-nuclear weapons
the ruins of our cities which have been
burned To The Ground by Russian bones
and artillery are similar to what I've
just seen here which was an honor for me
to be in this Museum of Peace thank you
so much that you gave me such an
opportunity
your people
what I have seen and what your people
have unfortunately seen in their history
instead of the normal life of thousands
and thousands of families only Ashes
Remain instead of cities there is a
scorched Wasteland instead of houses on
the rubble
Hiroshima is a rebuilt City and we dream
of rebuilding all our cities that are
now in Ruins and every village where not
a single house is left after Russian
Strife we dream of returning our
territories just as we have regained our
Northern Territories which were occupied
by Russia we must regain our listing and
Southern territories of Ukraine we dream
of returning our pieces who are now in
Russian captivity these are prisoners of
war and civilians deported
[Music]
for this to happen not only this
aggressor has to lose the ambition of
the war itself has to lose and this is
what is important for everyone in the
world I'm here in Hiroshima so that the
world can hear the Ukrainian call for
Unity from here Russia has trampled on
everything that is civilized it has been
occupying our largest nuclear power
plant the largest in Europe for over a
year now Russia is the only terrorist
state in the world that has fired tanks
at a nuclear power plant no one else has
ever used the nuclear power plant as a
training ground for weapons and shells
Russia is hiding behind the nuclear
power plant to fire
artillery at our cities if anyone in the
world is still able to ignore
Russia's other war crimes it's crime
against humanity should definitely
prompt action by everyone this is from
us Ukraine which had to endure the
radiation disaster of Chernobyl in 1986.
until now that's a Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski also speaking at
Hiroshima Japan on the final day of that
G7 Summit this of course after he had
met with the President Joe Biden and he
met with other world leaders attending
the G7 Summit and earlier we heard from
the U.S president who had announced that
the U.S is unveiling a 375 million
dollar military aid package for Ukraine